okay it's time I'm gonna try to bring
some levity in very serious times to you
during the voicemail segment the
voicemail number of course is two one
nine to david p here is an old folk who
is telling me david there are old folks
who watch watch your show take a listen
hey David
please don't see on your show that old
folks don't watch your show because
we're old folks and we watch your show
every day right thanks bye yeah no
listen what what I said was it is
disproportionately old folks that are
watching Fox News and we have more
younger folks that watch our show but of
course I know we have people of all ages
who watch our show we appreciate
everybody I'm glad that the old folks in
the audience are demanding recognition
we actually have we have a big a big
supporter of the show who's in his 90s
he lives here in the Boston area great
guy and has been a supporter for years
and we we know about it we love the old
folks we love the poorly educated we
love the well educated we love the old
folks we love the young folks we love
the Americans we love the non Americans
it's all it's all happening here but my
point was it's disproportionately old
folks watching Fox News not that there
are no old folks watching the David
Pakman show we have a very interesting
bonus show for you today which I hope
you will watch by grabbing a membership
at join pakman.com there is we've
wondered what happens if a coronavirus
patient refuses to quarantine we now
know deputies are surrounding his house
to force him to quarantine number two
Planet Fitness is offering free at-home
workout classes via livestream this
issue of keeping an exercise program
during this crisis is an important one
and we'll talk about it and then lastly
these tennis Tennessee brothers who
bought thousands of bottles of hand
sanitizer to be price gouging with now
they say they are sorry but what's
happening with the hand sanitizer that's
the question all of those stories and
more on today's bonus show get instant
access by becoming a member at join
pakman.com or a patron at patreon.com
slash david pakman show